arriva per tutti quel momento della vita
in cui bisogna fare quel passo in più in
cui bisogna prendersi cura di un piccolo
cucciolo che kakà anche un pò in giro di
essere umano siamo oggi qui è questo
tutorial per insegnare alle mamme
moderne come si fanno le mamme welcome
to my door simulator mas popular cv show
for the water noi inizio e arci flores
non so più capace telescope c'è la
modalità survival
ok proviamo la boe che record stars
hribal va bene che bello sto bambino
d'accordo ragazzi come vedreste di scafa
va bene questo device ifor spiegami ciao
figlio a ceva va a tempo ciuccio ci
tieni tesoro tinuccio fantastico e
adesso no perché sta facendo e masi
scemo ciuccio il ceco questo tratto sta
cacciando loro già sentita il ciuccio e
questo zio non so se hai capito è mai
adesso ciuccio che palla resta lì ho
capito solo sputi che doveva ingoiato
non avrò mai un figlio gesù cristo
ho vinto prima cosa da considerare di
oggi è che mio figlio non capisce un
cavolo aspiratore per bambini ma che va
bene allora senti se vuoi il ciuccio e
ti do il ciuccio ai sporco c'è credo sia
sporco il su ciò che aspetta e pulisco
come si pu lievi puliamo il ciuccio e
aprì a puliamo pulici tuo figlio
senti facciamo una roba decente menu
facciamo né l'altra modalità perché
questa non so sopravvivere a un bambino
ok meet the baby no perché non è
veramente possibile se senti di bambino
bambino capisce se vuoi il ciuccio poi
va bene vieni con me
cioè se i nudo se i nudo porca di una
vacca allora qua ma un bambino di gomma
ok ti tieni aspetta se con una mano
prendi lui lo poggi aspetta che ti do il
ciuccio
ecco chi è che o no dico e allora se non
hai capito come si sta al mondo cosa ci
sei venuto a fare al mondo spiega velo
cosa te piani telo dato tre volte il
ciuccio smetti ai piangeva sta allora
sentite c'è un problema di fondo il suo
gioco nonchè il mio figlio non capisce
come esiste alcun e si vive
cosa vuoi parla infante a c'è scritto lì
porca eva che ne so fammi leggere allora
ma non si legge niente ha però è sporco
prima di dare il ciuccio al bambino devi
lavarlo va in cucina e lava ok
prendiamo sto fottutissime maledetto
ciuccio ok lo infiliamo sotto il
lavandino sotto lava il lavello sotto
una gonna guarda sì ma non si lava e
rimane sporco allora che sai che
lavandino è spiegami e sporco
perché ovviamente se lo lasci nel
lavandino non si pulisce davis tendere
la mano
ovvio tieni bambino stupido gesù un'ora
m
grazie primo capezzolo sbloccato ma ci
va bene adesso ci sono
devo solo capire come pulire il ciuccio
però ci siamo beh 31 mag
allora giù ciò porta a prima porta a
prima dov'è il lavandino lavandino
lavandino ecco qua tira tira perché
perfetto o le mamma mia che mamma
modello che mamma mode the the cup a
questo che voi no poi un pannolino
pulito ti devo togliere il tuo
che schifo ho cercato di ma dove lo
butto
lo buttiamo vabbè tanto dice tutto
quindi pulisci serve il pannolino pulito
che non sono le sia però va bene lo
troviamo pannolini pannolini pannolini
puliti non trova i pannolini ami amore
mio non sai qual caso della mattina i
pannolini perché a me qua per terra
porca vacca o meno 10
la mia vita non vedo l'ora di essere
padre giuro c'è una modalità challenge
se non sono tre manco i pannolini per
capire cosa vuoi da merita spiega mi
prendi il pannolino
ok buttiamo il pannolino intanto c'è il
canestro
va bene grazie anche kobe bryant si
allenava così ecco qua perfetto prendilo
e mettilo rasi scemo cosa devo devo
mettere il talco prima che cagata quanto
è difficile fare la mamma
metti il talco a noi bambino lo devo
mettere al cospetto aspettano
ok no mi servirebbe adesso il pannolino
che era per terra prove o perfetto posso
prendere il bambino in avanti
la cena è servita questo sono curioso di
vederlo perché non so cucinare manco per
me stesso però è poi il biberon
ok devi andare devi qt devo cucinarlo
prima va bene allora aprica apri coso
pulisci ok tanto come fanno essere lerci
sti cosi spiegano che le assume allora
mettiamo prima questo qua dentro
no no k arca vacca pulisci riempì
effetto ora dove mettere il tappo giusto
magagna una roba devi fare quanti
problemi questa madre che li ho lavati
600 volte otto minuti per fare un
biberon metti lo metti o piano piano ho
pulito e continua gli sto dando più
acqua che chiaro ma pieni ma è che cosa
vuoi ci vuol molto dentro ma fammi
capire ad omettere porca vacca space
vita scritta effetto devo mettere sta
cosa qua dentro la candeggina
non so sicuro di mettercela
effettivamente però vabbè c'è più schifo
dentro stupì però anche sul pavimento di
casa mia guarda prove del nuovo prende
la sinistra non so cosa vuole messere un
cuba libre lo facciamo ma deve arrivare
i bambini di oggi mi fa bene di vogliono
vogliono le loro dentro i biberon sono
lì va bene no e finito il tempo ma porco
demonio morto già ci metto 6 ore almeno
quello porca vacca fatelo andare bene
perché mica un [ __ ] sbagliato era più
semplice affatto giuro
oddio grazie 1 quando usciva a scuola ti
mando adesso te fidati nello zaino team
filo tc mando che ha persino al tiro 5
euro vai al supermercato di compri
quello che vuoi e magni da solo mamma
mia che ansia next challenge ragazzi
apprestava modalità survival
praticamente bene vuoi il ciuccio
andiamo a pulire il ciuccio
mamma mia che ansia di vivere suo gioco
ho perso mio figlio dove ecco lo faccio
bene me l'aveva musica allegra da
nemmeno quello giacché il resto del
gioco non lo è almeno la musica ai ho
fame ho fame io il bambino che non ho
capito sto c io devo mangiare per me
stesso e magna da torta ma non capito
anzi ha mai sentito parlare di dieta non
so che chiedo io non si sa mai cosa vuoi
lurido bambino inutile biberon li
mortacci sua se non mi ricordo neanche
più come ho fatto a prepararlo prima
quindi non non sperate troppo ok
veneroso imparato bene allora un po di
bamba ok un po più di bamba ancora un po
di bamba lesbo che in teoria dovrebbe
essere a posto
vediamo tieni blu rido bimbo è il premio
papa dell'anno non va di sicuro a me
perché mi ha appena lanciato biberon ti
ammazzerei però vabbè poi ancora ce
l'avevi prima te magna de o meno male
che sto gioco è costato un euro e
cinquanta perché di filo non avrei
pagato giuro non ti sto arrestando stai
pure con le mani in basso
domani io dice di nuovo fame e iper
realistico sto gioco anch'io mangio così
io no non ho più cibo in realtà non so
come ci sono i wurstel
quasi quasi più star come siccome si
accende starò a li mangio così va bene
mangiati così che cos'è che vuoi o non
vuoi niente mi stai dicendo che sono una
madre libera mi ha guadagnato un sacco
di punti suo gioco allora per per premio
ti cambio pannolino guarda no freschi fo
non riesco a centrare il cestino molto
bene ho sporcato da per chi se ne frega
effetto perfetto perfetto perfetto
perfetto perfetto let's go me è perfetto
così
ho vinto veramente regalo vinto nel ci
credo ci stavo morendo di fame ho vinto
sono traguardi della vita questa
ma quanto sto giocando sta roba è che
gioco brutto dimmi cosa devo farmi mi
devo fare le stesse cose col pavimento
scivoloso
va bene c'è veramente chi ha scritturato
sta roba da uccidere
cerco il pavimento ghiacciato a tua
madre cioè già difficile così ma non ce
la farò mai impossibile infilate non ce
la farò mai veramente impossibile se già
così un casino ci provo ma non penso di
riuscirci che figo che però sarebbe
avere una casa così almeno per un giorno
gesù questi secondi che guadagno sono i
più preziosi lega perché poi
difficilissimo rimane poco tempo
cosa devo fare ho 30 secondi cosa vuoi
ancora lesbiche è finito perché non so
cos'altro fare
non so cos'altro fare perfetto
basta è stato orribile l'inferno pro
altro che era glaciale l'inferno ragazzi
miei basta basta pro ma mai più ma mai
veramente nella vita
e stato bello no non lo è stato
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto sono
un padre provetto o provetta non farò
mai
non farò spero che i ragazzi è bella
bella ragazza
[Musica]